[Captions by Y Translator]
Guys, we've got some cool
new shirts up in the shop.
I like this one.
It's pretty cool.
Got some nice "random happens"
writing on the sleeve.
Get yours now.
For thousands of years philosophers
have asked the question, what happens
if you put firecrackers in a toaster?
Well philosophers,
today is the day that we find out.
This is a standard ordinary toaster
and this is a firecracker.
It's little but it
packs a good amount of punch.
The premise is pretty simple.
We'll put a firecracker down
in the toaster,
turn the toaster on, back off
and see what happens.
If that goes well,
we'll try scaling it up
by using more firecrackers.
Will a firecracker light?
If it does light will it
damage the toaster?
Will the toaster explode?
That's what we want to learn.
Before we start throwing explosives down
inside heating devices.
We do want to go over a few
of the safety precautions
that we are taking.
You probably have noticed
that we're inside the dome.
It's a large concrete structure made
entirely of non flammable materials.
The floor, is made
of non flammable dirt.
We have pretty much nothing
flammable for about 20 feet.
Even though I don't think
that they are going to be
any flames shooting off of this.
Additionally, the top
of this dome which
does have a little skylight in it,
has been equipped with a spark arrestor.
So if there are sparks they
shouldn't be able to escape
and light anything on fire.
And we're also going to make sure
that we are well outside of the dome
whenever these go off.
The toaster takes a couple
of minutes to get hot.
We will put the firefighters down
into the toaster while it's cold,
push down on the toaster button
and then leave the dome entirely.
Everything is going
to be filmed with tripods.
There's a couple
reasons for that.
One, it eliminates the chance
of debris flying and hitting us.
Two, it's very echoey in the dome
and firecrackers are loud.
Any sound in here gets
magnified quite a bit
and even with earplugs we wouldn't
want to be inside when these go off.
Not only are we in a safe place,
but we also went ahead
and got a permit
from the local fire marshall
to be allowed to do this legally.
You may notice that we are
also kind of out here
in the middle of nowhere.
There's not much around
and there's a reason for that.
We're trying to be courteous
to our neighbors.
Regardless of how well this does
or doesn't work,
it's going to make a lot of noise
and we don't want to bother anyone.
As one final safety precaution, even
though there's pretty much nothing
that could be lit on fire.
We do have a couple of fire
extinguishers that we'll have on hand
and ready near the dome
but not inside just
in case there's something on fire in here
so that way if there is a surprise fire
we can make sure we can put those out
with our fire extinguishers.
Here we go, starting off
with a single firecracker.
Place that in,
it's just sitting nicely where
a slice of bread would sit.
Now we're going to press down
the button and leave the dome.
Here goes.
Probably take at least a minute
for it to heat up and we'll
see if it gets hot enough to ignite
the gunpowder fuse attached to that.
I think that's
what's gonna happen.
I think that the fuse
itself will ignite.
It's also possible that just
the radiant heat won't be enough
and we'll try this again.
Maybe tilting it in an angle to make sure
that that fuse is sort of in contact
with one of the heating elements.
I think it went off.
All right.
Let's see the damage.
Oh, the toaster.
The button on the toaster is still down
and these pop up when there's no longer
electricity to them.
So it did not destroy everything so badly
that the toaster stopped working.
Let's just turn that off.
Well, we got one to work, sure,
but our toaster's still
intact and that's not so fun.
So let's let's
scale this up a bit.
All right, definitely going
for quite a bit more this time.
All right, here we go.
I'll be interested
to see when--
It started.
That was some of them.
I don't know if it was all
of them. What we're going to do
is just let that run
for another minute.
I can see that the lever
on the toaster is still pressed down.
If nothing goes off for another minute
or two we'll actually just unplug
the toaster out here.
We've got an extension cord.
And just unplug that
so we know it's not adding
additional heat, let it cool off
for a couple minutes and then
go in and investigate.
So what I was about to say is that
once I see the footage I'm going
to be interested in seeing like,
how much it looks
like the toaster has heated up
before the firecrackers start going.
Does it wait
until it's glowing orange?
Does it go before that?
Is there like one fuse that's
touching a heating element?
And so that's going off sooner.
Find out.
Just don't want to be looking down
into an exploding toaster
as things are going off.
Nothing else is happening,
so we're going to unplug
the toaster from here.
As I do that watch
the lever just pop right up.
Now we'll just give that
a minute to cool down just
in case something's still going on.
Ooh, our toaster is smoking
quite a bit still.
It's probably just
all the burning paper.
Let's take
this toaster, remove it.
Oh, so the bottom
of this toaster kinda got blasted open.
Fire crackers did do something
to it, for sure.
I think that's how it's supposed
to be hold closed.
I don't know how it managed
to shoot itself open, but it did.
A lot of blown up
firecrackers right there.
Couple of them did not explode.
The ones without fuses did not explode
and that one with a fuse didn't explode.
But our toaster,
I mean it-- the lever stayed in.
Now it's unplugged
so it won't but the lever was still down
after everything exploded.
So it didn't
destroy everything.
Orange glow starting
to show up.
And then just all chaos
breaks loose at once.
It goes from nothing
to a hundred in two seconds.
That's great.
One firecracker was neat,
a bunch of firecrackers
was pretty good
but we've got a toaster still working
and a lot of leftover firecrackers.
So now we're just going
to fill this thing up.
We also have a couple
of these ground flowers
and a few of these sparklers.
We're just going to fit as much
as we can into the toasters
and then see what that does.
Toaster stuffed full
of firecrackers.
Let's find out
if it'll survive.
Book it!
Again, I want to see
the footage because I,
you know, I wonder if the flowers
or the sparklers will go off first
or the firecrackers will start first.
So much mystery.
Oh, that can't be
nearly all of them.
Something went off.
I heard a psssh, I'm wondering
if that was the flower.
Usually those burn
a little longer.
I think that was round one.
Merry Christmas, you filthy animal
and a Happy New Year.
I still don't think
that was all of them.
I think there's more.
The lever on the toaster's
still down.
There's kind of smoke
rising up out of it.
I assume that's all of
the burning paper that
the firecrackers are made out of.
I kind of want it to just
light on fire.
We'll see, maybe it'll happen.
Oh, it's on fire.
Oh now the fire went out.
It's on fire again.
I worry for the camera.
There's like fire
rising right up to it.
Yeah, you might want
to move that camera.
Plug your ears, back it off
because it's like,
about to melt the camera probably.
It's like, so dusty.
>> Toasters on fire.
The lever is still down
on that toaster, even
though the whole thing,
like literally the whole toaster is just
on fire this point.
I don't think it's quite reached
the plastic housing.
I think we're still burning paper,
but I'm impressed.
That's only like a seven
dollar toaster.
Oh there it goes.
I don't know if that
was timing or what.
Oh, and now
the flower went off.
I think it popping back up,
shifted things inside enough
that changed what did.
Now we just kind of have
to wait for few minutes.
Suspect most things
have now exploded.
We've now given
this toaster several minutes
while there were flames.
So I'm pretty sure anything that
was going to explode has exploded.
Yeah.
The fire was basically
the burnt paper shells
of the flowers just sitting there burning.
We have successfully
broken this toaster.
It's very hot.
Unsurprisingly.
It was on fire.
Of course it was hot.
Random fact, the average household
in the United States spends
about 35 hours a year making toast.
Here's the smoking remnants
from a whole bunch of firecrackers.
Couple other types
of fireworks and sparklers.
Twisted metal remains.
Well, we've wanted to know
since the dawn of time what happens
when you put firecrackers in a toaster
and that question has finally been
answered for all of mankind.
So explosions, flames shooting out
the top, melting the toaster itself,
all great stuff.
That is a big old pile of firework ash
and our toaster is quite
thoroughly ruined.
The lever doesn't even
stay down now, even
if it is plugged in.
It's just broken.
I don't know exactly what part broke,
probably several.
Guys, this was awesome.
But that's not all,
we've always got more for you to see.
The Box up at the top
will transport you directly
to our last video
and you should check that out.
The other box will show you what
YouTube thinks you should be watching next
and if you aren't subscribed
to our channel yet just hit
this bomb to get in the club.
That way you never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.